the real key is you've got to learn to
compartmentalize so what i do to begin
my compartmentalization is i create a
list
of all the important things that i
should be working on
i put that list in order this is very
important getting good at prioritizing
is an art form it is critically
important that you get good at that art
form and as you begin to break things
down and put them in order now you can
tell yourself hey this is what i should
be working on right now so rather than
trying to digest all the different
things that have to be done it's i'm
focused on this one thing right now and
my only job right now is to focus on
that thing and so by not letting your
mind wander and this meditation is very
good at bringing your focus back to the
breath which teaches you to bring your
focus back to whatever so you can do
everything that you want to do just not
all of it at once